welcome to this video playing
Rachmaninoff that's got no flakin there
no name no okay playing the English
Defence IAM and let's see what this
grandmasters playing against it yup
that's a good line it's in fact the line
that I've played myself against this is
wide when I was still playing c4
regularly I still do but there was a
time where I'm almost exclusively played
c4 and sometimes you would get b6 and I
was going for that that set up that the
white players choosing him I played
rookie one though not a three
an interesting night to deform
yeah maybe just take it and queen age
for activating the Queen I have a soft
spot for Queen edge for anyway but it
looks it looks like okay here I mean he
had the idea to play Queen age five
maybe so this is now prevented I'm not
threatening on defo of course because of
Bishop Bishop age seven but i might have
Knight to c6 this is probably the way to
develop this piece and then 97 12 or 97
g6 F for these kind of ideas it also i
think it's better to put it on c6 and
not on let's say after d6 on d7 se6 is
seriously weakened if you place d5 now I
have 95 looks very nice actually 925
Saudi 5 is probably not so great well I
think this is a pretty decent for like I
don't have a particularly bad piece I
can get night e72 f5 in how interesting
is may be preparing bishop f2 and okay I
can go to g5 this is not not a not an
issue
trying to to trade
mmhmm yeah i'm unsure we should trade
queens or not it's not particularly bad
if i trade them but i didn't expect that
but okay see sadness maybe really
hanging yeah i cannot easily protect the
pond way that's that's tricky i wanted
to play without d6 would have been
prevalent preferable ok they actually
traded queens i don't know you can force
this anyway but ok but Queen g5 is not
not an ideal move and the pawn only six
ok well it's not easily attacked them
and I'm threatening night f5 here to get
rid of his bishop pair if you're just
hmm interesting so maybe it couldn't do
much about it
I thought that this should be really am
very equal now if I get one of his
bishops take he am let's even look f6 g6
maybe on a good day I'll get some attack
going what does six not exactly as he
doing here if I go here this F 4 + d 4 +
t2 attacked overlooking something here
something i don't i don't really know i
mean if i win c4 i would would lead to
an excellent position as i have been a
fantastic spot on d5
okay if I take Carrie multiplayer uxie
one I guess hmm I wonder rook f7 maybe
takes rook see one I really I can he get
cereal get c 7 which is not great ok
let's let's protect this for the moment
it's um it wasn't bad to to get this in
any way and now I may be really
threatening rook f3 ok so we trippy
prevents that Queen g6 again threatening
hook f3 or just trade it
not sure okay
yeah well its of course it's of course
very equal now but I was I was getting a
bit ambitious and because I well maybe
maybe I could have done something here
not wasn't but I didn't really I
couldn't really make anything great work
so just play this position now I want to
play b5 breaking up this on the
queenside okay maybe you just hear it
also protects be seven so an attack yes
not the problem look be 1 or 0 k 7i can
just take it on deform okay that's
interesting if I take it it will take it
seven play route 87 that's a good idea
okay so let's just drop back I can play
gphone oops oops my rook
rookie 5 I can't play rookie five but
ugly Oh time warnings not really going
for that yeah well that's a shame I mean
it was almost impossible to really get
back into tree to trouble and then
manage their setting up this totally
totally unlucky position of pieces
that's a bit frustrating he never had
anything in this game being best equal
most of the time okay black resigns yeah
just just screwed this up terribly if
the rook on f5 I mean here I'm just I'm
just okay there's nothing going on I
just need to to be precise IAM and well
maybe the rook is already a bit tricky
on on a five-man maybe it is of course
it's totally unnecessary you can play
whatever you want to just nothing going
on even after a five I mean okay maybe I
should just play a book like age 5 or
something I mean just prevent g-form and
term also nothing happening I'm curious
he had he had simply overlooked Queen d3
and was a bit lucky that it wasn't
instantly losing something but I think
maybe I him here here there must be
something Bishop a six is the way to do
it
I didn't think about this one just
taking it day with the bishop yeah maybe
I mean even even this is of course quite
good for black but it's not like totally
convincing you only have rather symbolic
advantage here with the Queen on d5 it's
it's not there's nothing substantial
happening really on maybe this one I
don't know my term looks a bit passive
but there's nothing going on really yeah
Bishop a 6 this is the way to go yeah
thats it's not not exactly difficult to
see you cannot really play this I just
to just take it of course and John
Jeremy needs to do something like that's
probably check yeah that's not all
and then I don't know b5 you get 7
whatever this this rook c3 now so maybe
this to protect ya okay only black can
be better yeah i'm just a pawn up for
the moment he has chances of course to
get it back but it's a very comfortable
and better than the game of course after
which it was equal but I'm this really
curious when it started to get through
him i King f7 I kf7 is just bad just a
bad idea getting this look into into
this kind of precarious situation yeah
and here it's already a bit tricky
because I cannot easily he cannot easily
keep the bishop on the long diagonal I
mean as long as it stays here I always
have this counter threats OG for is not
easily possible but that sets already
really tricky empty five yeah yeah I'm
worse much worse that he played really
nicely d Fife was strong but here I'm
already in bad shape this is this is
already took a half no square on the
fifth-ranked and he's threatening Mook
87 here if I go e5 maybe five and then
Bishop to see eight if he plays look sm
hmm yeah I'm not lost here he is just
just getting very uncomfortable g5 maybe
you form yeah this is this is borderline
really maybe maybe black can hold this
but it's it's already quite bad already
quite bad some quite remarkable can you
have 70 this is just a bad idea exposing
the rook there or let's say yeah
hampering of the roots movements oh yeah
so I should just I mean I can also just
drop it back I mean there's not nothing
going on but I wanted to do it it would
be more actively and really didn't see
that the rook is in this kind of tricky
spot alright thanks for watching